ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
muchas gracias uno de los motivos por
los que la gente empieza a estudiar la
carrera de ingeniería informática es
porque previamente han tenido alguna
experiencia con la programación o
simplemente porque les gusta programar
para esta gente al principio la carrera
pues les es un poco decepcionante porque
empezaron a estudiar muchas asignaturas
de matemáticas de álgebra de lógica de
estadística algo de física y bastantes
fundamentos relacionados con la
computación y eso al principio pues no
les mola porque lo que les mola es
programar yo por ejemplo no elegí
estudiar ingeniería informática por la
programación ni por ni porque tuviese
una motivación en especial por la
informática yo elegí a estudiar
ingeniería informática por dos motivos
uno porque quería tener una carrera
universitaria y dos porque era la
facultad que más cerca me pillaba de
casa si tardaba 10 minutos andando así
que como no tenía ninguna motivación
especial pues al principio me dedicaba a
estudiar las asignaturas pues para ir
aprobando las y la verdad que me fue
bastante bien cuando empecé a tener
asignaturas relacionadas con la
programación y rompí la primera curva de
aprendizaje
pues empecé a notar que la carrera que
había elegido estudiar pues empezaba a
ser un poco interesante los primeros
programas que hacía que los hacían un
lenguaje que se llama pascal eran
programas muy sencillos de calcular
números primos números perfectos y demás
y eran programas que me llevaban pocas
líneas de código luego la cosa se empezó
a complicar cuando ya tuve que hacer
programas más complejos en particular un
programa que consistía en la gestión del
stock de una tienda que no solo tenía
que gestionar el stock sino que también
tenía que ofrecer a los clientes en
función de su perfil pues qué productos
les podían ser de su interés para ello
me dieron unos requisitos un conjunto de
reglas que como si de una receta de
cocina se tratase pues tuve que ir
programando eran reglas del estilo de
ofrecer a los hombres de entre 18 y 25
años un determinado producto oa las
mujeres mayores de 30 años con hijos
pues otro producto y bueno este programa
pues como ya fue un poco más complicado
ya me llevo unas cientos e incluso miles
de líneas de código desarrollarlo
otra cosa que estudiamos los ingenieros
informáticos es una cosa que se llama
algorítmica en la algorítmica nos
enseñan un conjunto de recetas que se
llaman algoritmos que sirven para
resolver pues una serie de problemas que
tienen que cumplir unas ciertas reglas
unas ciertas restricciones uno de esos
problemas no los encontramos en nuestro
día a día como es el de encontrar el
camino más corto que hay entre dos
puntos pues el camino más corto que haya
de mi casa al trabajo de mi casa al
restaurante donde ha quedado para comer
con los amigos otro de los problemas que
también resuelve el algorítmica es
hay aquí un problema vale
vale es lo que se conoce como el
problema del viajante vale el problema
el viajante es un problema muy típico
que consiste en que un viajante tiene
que partir de una ciudad tiene que
recorrer tiene ciudades volver a la
ciudad de origen y no puede repetir
pisar dos veces una misma ciudad y tiene
que encontrar la ruta más corta este
problema lo tienen por ejemplo las
empresas de mensajería que estaría muy
bien que el mensajero antes de salir a
hacer el reparto ya tuviese calculada
cuál sería la ruta que fuese hacer más
rápida pues para tardar menos ahorrar
gasolina y demás para ello se utilizan
unos algoritmos que se llaman algoritmos
de fuerza bruta que lo que consiste en
es en calcular todas las rutas posibles
que se pueden hacer entonces este
problema está muy bien si tienes cinco
rutas o cinco perdón cinco puntos de
entrega o cinco ciudades porque tienes
12 rutas diferentes entonces con 12
rutas pues puedes calcular muy fácil
cuál es la ruta más corta si ya tienes
10 ciudades o 10 puntos de entrega la
cosa se complica y tenemos 181 mil rutas
diferentes
pero la cosa se complica todavía mucho
más si tenemos 30 ciudades o 30 puntos
de entrega en el que ya tenemos 10
elevado a 30 y unas rutas diferentes no
nos vayamos al problema de 30 ciudades
vayámonos al problema de 10 ciudades
suponer un ordenador que nos calcula una
ruta por segundo lo que tardaría en
darnos el resultado pues algo más de dos
días de manera similar o con algoritmos
similares un algoritmo de malvas
tracking podemos resolver por ejemplo
todos los sudokus del mundo y este
algoritmo pues lo que hace es que se va
a la siguiente posición rellena con
todos los números posibles cogemos el
primer tablero válido y seguimos
rellenando sucesivamente si en algún
punto nos quedamos atascados volvemos al
estado anterior y seguimos rellenando
las las casillas esto está muy bien pero
cuantas soluciones tienen los sudokus
pues bueno un sudoku de 2 x 2 tiene 5
soluciones posibles y un sudoku de 4 x 4
tiene 288 soluciones posibles pero qué
es lo que pasa con un sudoku de 9 x 9
pues que tiene un orden de magnitud de
10 elevado a 21 soluciones
para que veáis un poco la complejidad
que tiene todo esto los segundos que han
pasado desde el big band hasta nuestros
días es de 435 por 10 elevado a 17
segundos vale imaginar ponéis un
ordenador a completar un sudoku por
segundo o incluso ponéis todos los
ordenadores que hay en el mundo a
completar un sudoku por segundo y
calcular cuántas eternidades tardaríamos
en hacer un programa que resolviese
todos los sudokus bueno no lo calcula y
son muchas eternidades es un cálculo un
cálculo rápido pero con estos algoritmos
también podemos resolver otros juegos
por ejemplo cuántas partidas diferentes
podemos jugar a las damas pues 10
elevado a 31 partidas diferentes cuantas
partidas podemos jugar al ajedrez de
unos 20 o 30 movimientos 10 elevado a
123 123 partidas o incluso a un juego
que se llama algo el gol tiene 10
elevado a 360 partidas posibles con lo
cual es inviable construir programas con
este tipo de algoritmos que sean
invencibles
bien
como comenta al principio esa carrera
que elegí sin ningún tipo de motivación
llegó un día en el que tuve que ir a una
asignatura que se llamaba inteligencia
artificial
y cuando termino en esa clase me dije a
mí mismo yo de mayor me quiero dedicar a
la inteligencia artificial sí porque
resulta que en esa clase el profesor nos
contó que que imitando la inteligencia
humana y la inteligencia natural éramos
capaces de resolver problemas que hasta
entonces o con los algoritmos que ha
estado contando eran inviables o
inabordables de resolver nos contó cosas
por ejemplo que imitando el
comportamiento que tienen las hormigas
que son animales prácticamente ciegos y
que se mueven al azar somos capaces de
encontrar el camino más corto entre dos
puntos porque las hormigas desde su
desde su nido hasta la fuente de
alimentos encuentran el camino más corto
también nos contó que gracias a la
computación evolutiva que está inspirada
en los mecanismos de evolución biológica
propuestos propuestos por darwin somos
capaces de resolver problemas de
semana el nombre de optimización
combinatoria vale como el problema del
viajante por ejemplo ya lo podemos
resolver en unos tiempos bastante
aceptables también nos contó que gracias
al aprendizaje por refuerzo que es cómo
se educa o se adiestra a los animales
somos los robots son capaces de aprender
por ellos mismos a no chocarse a no
tropezarse a no caerse por las escaleras
vale también nos contó cosas tan
interesantes como ésta que gracias a los
descubrimientos que hizo en su día ramón
y cajal de cómo estaba formado el
cerebro y de cómo estaba compuesto el
cerebro fuimos capaces de imitarlo y
construir redes neuronales artificiales
que son capaces de resolver problemas
muy complejos de aprender por ellas
solas y de resolver problemas que lo
resolverían como cómo lo resolvemos las
las personas cómo lo resuelve un cerebro
humano en definitiva nos contó que con
la inteligencia artificial somos capaces
de resolver muchos problemas que antes
eran inabordables o muy difíciles de
resolver en unos tiempos
en unos tiempos finitos
pero también nos contó una cosa en esa
clase que a mí la verdad que me chocó un
poco y es que nos contó que la
inteligencia artificial nació en el año
1950 cuando alan turing cuando alan
turing propuso el conocido test de
turing y yo pensé en aquel momento que
han pasado algo más de 50 años y no veo
que la inteligencia artificial haya
calado mucho entre nosotros y como todo
en la vida tiene sus pros y tiene sus
contras y es que la inteligencia
artificial necesita de muchos datos y
necesita de muchos ejemplos para poder
aprender y para poder tener éxito pero
también necesita de muchos ordenador
también necesitan ordenadores lo
suficientemente potentes que sean
capaces de procesar todos esos datos y
durante muchos años no hemos tenido ni
datos ni ejemplos ni ordenadores pero
ahora la cosa ha cambiado ahora ya
tenemos muchos datos tenemos muchos
ejemplos tenemos ordenadores muy
potentes que son capaces de procesar
todos esos datos
hay un cambio de paradigma en todo esto
ya no somos las personas ya no son los
programadores ya no somos los ingenieros
informáticos los que tenemos que estar
ahí
escribiendo programando infinitas reglas
para definir cuál es el comportamiento
que tiene que tener un ordenador no no
ya son gracias a las técnicas de
inteligencia artificial al machine
learning a los datos los que van a
aprender por ellos mismos sus propias
reglas y van a saber ellos mismos
resolver los problemas
hay un cambio de paradigma en todo esto
y con todo esto sabéis que conseguimos
cosas tan interesantes como el coche
autónomo por ejemplo si mi hija que
nació en el año 2016 probablemente no
tenga la necesidad de aprender a
conducir porque cuando ella sea mayor ya
los coches autónomos serán totalmente
seguros y serán colaborativos entre sí
para evitar atascos y para y para que
haya menos contaminación o cosas más
chulas que tenemos en nuestro día a día
como los robots que ya nos barren la
casa verdad o los asistentes virtuales
que tú les haces una pregunta y ya te
responden en lenguaje natural incluso
después decir que te pidan una pizza
para que te la traigan a casa y te la
traen no los robots el pizzero te atrae
y luego también podemos en la medicina
la inteligencia artificial puede ayudar
a los médicos a mejorar los diagnósticos
si les damos muchos análisis les damos
muchas radiografías les damos muchas
resonancias son capaces de aprender qué
patologías sufrimos y son capaces de
ayudar a los médicos a dar mejores
diagnósticos o cosas incluso que ya han
pasado como que en el año 1997 la
inteligencia artificial fue capaz de
ganar al ajedrez a kasparov si aquel
juego que tenía tantísimas soluciones
que no podíamos resolver en una
infinidad de eternidades pues si la
inteligencia artificial ha conseguido
ganar a kasparov o también ha conseguido
ganar en el año 2016 a todo un campeón
del mundo de go
o lo que es todavía más chulo la
inteligencia artificial ha conseguido
pintar a la perfección un cuadro de
rembrandt o lo que es más increíble aún
sabéis lo que ha conseguido la
inteligencia artificial que yo sea un
excelente pintor cubista casi tan bueno
como picasso mirar que autorretrato más
chulo me he hecho con la inteligencia
artificial y con mis redes artificiales
la inteligencia artificial
está para quedarse y va a suponer un
cambio muy grande en nuestras vidas y
está suponiendo un cambio muy grande en
nuestras vidas de hecho está propiciando
lo que ya se conoce como la cuarta
revolución industrial tenemos una
herramienta muy poderosa en nuestras
manos y como dice la frase todo gran
poder lleva una gran responsabilidad dos
de los visionarios más relevantes de los
últimos años como los más o steve
hopkins nos advierten de los riesgos
potenciales que tienen la inteligencia
artificial incluso este hijo kim dice
que va a terminar con la humanidad la
inteligencia artificial pero no la
inteligencia artificial las tenemos que
controlar las personas y somos nosotros
los que tenemos esa herramienta tan
poderosa para construir un mundo mejor
con menos desigualdades y mucho más
justo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]